for a lot of offers it would be typical
to go to the next battle and not go to
the aftermath and what what did you feel
was the motivation behind that for you
what made you so interested in that you
know Shakespeare has a in in Henry v
there's a sequence right before the the
Battle of Agincourt where prince how
Henry v is is is in disguise and he's
wandering among his men and you know
some of the the common men are saying I
hope that the Kings causes just because
of its not you know the awful price
we're gonna pay in in severed limbs and
slaughtered and lakes of blood and all
that and how reacts very negatively this
and gives a long speech about though
it's not for you peasant to judge
whether the Kings causes just it's you
know God will weigh on this and all that
Shakespeare of course writing during and
the Tudor dynasty to appease to the
Tudor kings but it's a profound question
it's that's often asked and the truth is
we we we look at war through most of
human history and you can ask where any
of them just you know were the wars that
I mean Charles the 12th is a fascinating
character who I've read about and
studied you know came to the came to a
crown at 14 years of age died at 36
spent his entire reign fighting hardly
was ever home one war another why any of
these wars necessary or any of these
Wars worth anything did it improve
anything for anybody except for him you
know his his legend and and whatever you
know you you look at some of these wars
up in medieval times and it's like what
difference did it make to the common man
which Lord had dominion over them it's
not like they were fighting for
political systems were or
anything like that it was all kind of
the same you know and you really wonder
about it I don't think that's true of
all wars but it's certainly true of many
of them if you study history in us
that's something I want my readers to to
ask themselves about it now Toki and the
most fantasies make it make it very
clear that the war is worthwhile because
after all it's it's like you know evil
slobbering works are coming and if they
win they're going to you know kill
everybody and and eat man flesh and
great darkness will settle over the
earth well okay yeah but let's not make
it that easy